I grew my Instagram account to about two
hundred thousand then I got hacked
literally the FBI got involved which is
really weird to have to call the police
which the FBI told me I had to do and be
like hi right now I'm trying to log into
Twitter
and I can't also my Instagram someone
has is like on my Instagram and they're
like ma'am we'll send a car literally
they send a car to my house I was like
oh and I was crying because it's like my
it's everything at that point that my
whole business is on social media and so
I think even though so much of what
you've been learning the last two days
is about social think about the business
side of it you will outshine the
competition If instead of focusing on
likes and the all those vanity metrics
you start thinking about like how do I
get people on my email list because when
the police came to my house and my
account was hacked I mean I was kind of
freaking out but by the same token I
already had an email list of over 200
000 and this is back in 2015. so I knew
I was gonna be okay